interest you know the banks yeah Prophet
Muhammad told us it will come a time
when interest will become widespread
even if you are not involved directly
will affect you indirectly remember the
prophet
Muhammad existed 1,400 years ago so
during his lifetime there was no
indication or any indication to indicate
that interest will become widespread Now
by default if you open a bank account
you are involving interest even if you
tell them look I'm Muslim I don't want
to have interest they still use your
money for interest so the question you
should ask yourself how a man that
existed 1,400 years ago was able to
prophesize about something which we can
observe right now because that man is a
messenger of Allah the most high okay
even in the Old Testament the Old
Testament speaks about the Prophet
Muhammad in Isaiah 42 are you familiar
with the Old Testament with the Bible
yeah I don't read the Bible as much as I
used to you know about Isaiah yeah
Isaiah if you go to Isaiah 42 it speaks
about the prophet the the messenger who
will come to the kada and if you go to
Genesis 2513 K is the son of ishma so
when you look to Islam what distinguish
Islam from any religion Islam is based
upon Universal proofs Okay and like the
B was telling you look you can live this
life any time and I'll tell you the
reason people don't not accept Islam it
goes back to two
factors either is a psychological factor
or social Factor what is psychological
Factor psychological Factor there the
things you do for example maybe I smoke
drugs I drink alcohol and I if I accept
Islam I have to so what do I have to do
that's what I'm saying but this is Satan
that's a Satan deception because you
accepting Islam doesn't not make you
perfect all of us here we I've been born
as a Muslim likewise we have our own
struggles but there's difference between
negating your Creator and committing
sins for example to give you analogy
imagine you have two daughters okay one
of them is naughty now and then but she
accept you her mother she said sorry to
you the other daughter she said you know
what you know even my mother I don't
care about you which one is worse the
first or the second first one second no
the second the second the second yeah
the second the second you know why the
sick doesn't recognize your
your you g you give birth child so on
yeah so so about God which is more worse
that God gave you everything while we
speaking we benefited from God's oxygen
if you go to hospital may Allah forbid
what will happen to you you have to pay
for the oxygen you with
me don't let this interrupt you from God
God is the most important okay
Sor all right sorry for taking your time
let me so the point here is while we
speaking we are benefiting from God's
oxygen if you go to hospital Allah
forbid and they have to give you oxygen
they will charge you yes so IM imagine
all these blessings that you have from
God for free then God asks you one thing
worship him alone and do not associate
anything as a partner with him and look
how many people are working you no
guarantee this life is not there's no
guarantee in this life except death so
how many people left the house they
never come back how many people when
sleep they never wake up so if it makes
sense to you is it clear to you don't
let nothing stop stop you because
recognizing the Creator when you accept
Islam you don't have to fly you know
there's no one test there's no one
worthy of worship except Allah and I
bear witness that Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah this is the two
testimony when you accept Islam there
step by step okay the prayer covering
all of that step by step and the example
I give about the cake okay imagine you
have a big cake front of you nice like
chocolate cake yeah if you eat all of it
what will happen to you at once you get
a sick in order for you to feel the the
sweetness of the cake what you do bit by
bit likewise when it come to Islam step
by step but the most important thing is
what recognizing accepting Allah
believing his Prophet Muhammad because
when you believe in his Prophet Muhammad
you believe in Prophet Jesus in the
correct way not the way of the pagans
okay sister so don't let nothing stop
you li don't let stop understand so say
except Islam then you learn step by step
like I said to you Satan will try to
everything to stop you from accepting
the truth you understand so that's why
the brother was saying you if you have
your worst enemy would you would you
take him as your advisor no you will not
that's what happened to you now what's
happening within you there is an angel
pushing you to accept the truth and a
Satan so follow the way of the Angel
which is the servant of God ready aldah
I'm gonna say Arabic then translate
English Okay say
Muhammad Allah in English I bear witness
there's nothing worthy of worship in
truth except Allah and I bear witness
that Muhammad is the last messenger and
the servant of Allah aldah you Muslim
sister aldah very happy for you look my
sister
look actually read look sister I'll give
you a reminder even to my sister here
okay all of us here you know this life
there's a lot of ATT Temptation no doubt
for you and for us as a man and as a
woman yes but I advise you like what the
prophet Muhammad advised us with visit
the graveyard there are people like you
and me same Ed as you and same Ed as me
now they have passed away and they are
in the graves this life God will test us
but all this test the reason Allah told
us to not drink or to not fornicate or
to not smoke drugs not because because
Allah hat us because Allah love us and
he want good for us and this life is a
test you know look Prophet Muhammad told
us if a man really loves a woman should
marry her because when a man see nice
woman always say I love you but he just
wants something you know what I'm
talking about you understand so why
advice to you alhamdulillah you are now
you are like sinless except Islam of
course based upon Justice if you have a
debt you should pay it off but whatever
between Allah is been removed now Satan
is going to come hard on you you know
why cuz now you are in the straight path
and now you're going to have connection
with your creator so choose the
Hereafter better than this life to
conclude with and uh thank you for
giving me your time I'm going to give
you
analogy imagine in a winter time when
it's very very cold okay I come to both
you I said I have two houses for you one
house is made out of plastic and one
house is made out of gold I will give
you the house is made out of gold but
you only stay one day and the rest of
the winter you're going to stay outside
or I will give you the house that is
made out of plastic and wood but you
stay forever I mean all your life which
one you going to choose the wood because
I want to be warm long that's what I'm
say so imagine this life is a life which
is made out of plastic and wood and the
paradise is made out of gold and silver
and diamond and whatever you desire so
any person the sound reasoning will
choose the Hereafter over this life you
understand so don't let
Temptation become Muslim alhamdulillah
work hard more to please your creator
because Allah the paradise is so
valuable of course you're going to
struggle have my own struggles like I
said Islam we have the concept of
forgiveness no one is going to die for
your sins if you commit sin ask Allah
for forgiveness forgiveness try your
best to not go back to it and always
look for good friends M says good I know
very well she works there you
know have to help
her and pray okay take care of yourself
may Allah bless you you're welcome take
care